e o arrependimento quando a gente sem
querer pisa no rabo de um cachorro então
um cachorro é um bicho que parece que
transborda tanto amor que a gente se
sente me irmão a coisa mais ruim do
mundo a pessoa deitada no chão tu passa
sem querer pisa na perna tu fala é só um
humano agora quando você pisa na patinha
do cachorro meu amigo quando tu escuta
aquele som ai ai ai aquilo ali é o som
de Deus dizendo assim o que tu fizestes
filho tu já vira para trás assim ó
perdão Joli E para piorar tu olha pro
cachorro ele tá com essa cara aqui
ó me desculpa cachorrinho deixa eu
beijar sua patinha oh meu Deus s des
bosta Mig mas é tão cheirosinho me
desculpa me desculpa quando eu vou na
casa de alguém que tem cachorro e eu me
apego o cachorro na hora de ir embora
meu amigo é um parto não eu vou voltar
pequeno cachorrinho eu vou brincar com
você vou fazer tudo que os seus donos
não fazem eu vou correr eu vou voltar eu
vou me deitar no chão vou deixar você
lamber a minha boca que eu sei que é o
que você mais gosta de fazer mas ninguém
gosta que cachorro lambe a boca porque
pensa que ele é muito sujo e come merda
mas você merece todo o amor do mundo e
eu posso cheirar sua patinha para sempre
Ai meu Deus